hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from the prestigious
mr dodgy invitational uh it's
simon williams versus daniel dubois both
of them are
really really awesome attackers and if
you ask either of them they're
they're probably gonna say that they're
pretty boring players you know nothing
fancy nothing
crazy is happening uh but those would be
very modest answers as we all know both
of them
really enjoy some uh awesome attacking
chess
so without further ado let's check it
out as simon has the white pieces
and he opens with e4 daniel goes for the
sicilian defense we have c5
knight to f3 uh d6 and now d4
so all very standard stuff going for the
open sicilian captures capture snipe to
f6
and now knight to c3 and now although
there are
plenty of good options here uh for this
game the new opts for uh
knight to c6 so the classical variation
and bishop to g5 going for the
rita rouser variation we have e6 and now
again there are uh
many many ideas here that have been
played uh
thousands of times queen to d2 being the
most popular one preparing queenside
castle
uh simon goes for queen to d3 it's not a
new move but it's not as
as played as queen to d21 and uh daniel
continues development with bishop to d7
queen side castles and
now uh a6 uh always a useful move as
black's plan is playing something like
b5 rook c bringing the queen over to a5
and start some sort of a queen side
attack as the black king for the moment
is in the center of the board
but will castle king side at some point
then we're gonna have a castles of
opposite sides and it's gonna be a race
of course
so f4 uh continuing the expansion on the
king's side and now
bishop to e7 now we have captures on c6
bishop captures
and now this position has been reached
before known moves are e5 and f5
but here 7 goes for the prophylactic
king to b1
and it is already as of movie 11 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
how daniel continues this
uh he also castles now and now uh well
there are some other moves that could be
played simon goes for his signature move
and that is of course pushing harry the
h
pawn and he pushes it to h4 so here we
have b5 daniel does the same he wants to
start the attack on the queen side and
here uh what do you do well here uh
you kind of want to start by playing g4
but you can do this right away because
uh well
for for one the knight is attacking it
so here simon eliminates the knight with
bishop captures on f6 and then he can
continue harassing the bishop maybe
later on with the g4 g5
another way to continue this might be
something like e5 and then we could have
some
nice knight to d5 maybe attacking the
bishop going for the knight on c3
maybe queen g3 and then this game is
played but that's for
for a different video so to say so
instead after
b5 like we said bishop captures an f6
bishop captures and
now well you wanna push that pawn to g4
you can't do it just yet because here
uh daniel would just have too easy of a
game he would just capture on c3 and now
there really isn't a good move here
uh if queen captures then bishop
eliminates the e4 pawn
and if of course the b the b pawn
captures then you ruined your king side
queen to a5 is coming in it's uh it's
not
that great of a position for white so
instead
knight the e2 not allowing this capture
and
now simon is ready to start pushing on
the king's side we have queen to a5
bringing the queen into the attack and
now knight to d4
going for the undefended bishop on c6 we
have rookie to see it
you could also move the bishop back
daniel prefers rook 8 to c8
and now uh that everything is has been
nicely placed g4 now simon wants to
start pushing on the king's side uh we
have bishop captures on the e4
although uh this is uh maybe a move you
don't want to play because you really
want your bishop here but it's not like
it's a fiance
bishop on g7 here it's very vulnerable
here only one move and you will have to
uh either either trade it or bring it
back to e7 and you really don't want it
on e7 and you don't want to play some
like g6 here because then you only give
white uh more targets to to attack with
his pawn so here
uh daniel just captures it we have queen
captures and then now uh a beautiful
beautiful move by daniel uh
e5 and this is a this is a straight out
pawn sacrifice but if uh
white accepts this for example captures
captures and captures then a simple just
rook to e8 and uh well you are you are
winning your pawn back
and uh white doesn't really have any
sort of an attack you only have two
pawns here now
and black still hasn't extended any of
the pawns uh to use as targets
so instead after e5 simon brings the
queen back queen to e3 but now
daniel achieved what he wanted to
achieve he wanted to eliminate the f
pawn because without the f pawn you do
not get f5 and then the e6 square
has been vacated for the bishop and the
bishop will be used for attacking
white's queen side
so here we have e captures on f4 queen
captures and bishop to d7 now
the bishop will be completely safe on e6
because white doesn't have a d-pawn or
an f-pawn to
challenge this light square bishop from
black
and here grabbing this pawn doesn't
really do anything it's just a
meaningless pawn grab
black will just continue with his plan
start attacking and already you know
good things are happening for
uh for daniel so instead after bishop to
d7 we have
h5 uh simon continues pushing his hairy
pawn
and now bishop to e6 now threatening
queen captures on a2 so of course this
has to be defended
and simon defends it with a3 b3 would
have been
a bit more uh well uh solid
because there's no way to break through
right away but you kind of have to worry
about something like
queen to c3 then how do you defend this
maybe rook to h2 maybe you try to defend
it like this
it it's looking very uh very shaky but
still it it's better than a3 because
after a3
now daniel has a clear target and he of
course uh
seizes it right away he plays b4 uh now
uh ready to open up the queen side and
simon says all right we're not waiting
for any of this we continue pushing our
harry pawn
h6 and now uh who's faster daniel plays
b
captures on a3 simon plays h captures on
g7
and his h pawn harry the h pawn already
reached the the g7 square
now uh you know white is also very close
to checkmating black but the only
problem is
uh daniel has a forced checkmate in nine
moves as the title suggests
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this
uh well uh sort of an elusive idea while
i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on not starting
with something like a characters on b2
well this is fine it's not a forced
checkmate but black will win this game
and for those of you who played bishop
a2 with
check congratulations as this is now a
forced checkmate and
we can even do i know you guys want it
we can even do this guy in slow motion
so there you have it the bishop to a to
check
and that's it now the bishop has to be
accepted if you don't accept the bishop
uh whatever you play this comes with
check that's the point for example
check uh the king the queen covers the
d2 square the bishop car is b1 so the
pawn has to be accepted
and after king captures now we just
finished the game rook b8
czech king c1 for example and rook to b1
checkmate as
once again uh the queen covers the the
escape square so that's not an option
after bishop to a to check the bishop
must be accepted but now the king is on
a2 and that's
that's trouble so here daniel captures
eight captures on b2 with
check a discovery from the queen king
captures and
now queen to c3 with check so if you go
to c1 this is just checkmate so you have
to move the king away from the c
pawn king the a2 was played but now
queen captures on c2
with check king to a1 uh and now queen
captures on d1 with
check and he was in this position on
move 27 that simon williams resigned the
game
uh without even allowing uh mate to
appear on the board but as usual we will
show the
entire variation so here after this
queen to d1 check you don't really have
a lot of moves
king to a2 the most resilient one
although it's not pretty and then we
just finish with
rook to c to check king a3 queen to a1
check king to b4 and now we bring our
last piece into the game we don't have
to we can also play a queen to c3
but you know let's involve as many
pieces as possible that's always
nice to do and now the white king has no
more squares you have only one move left
the block with the bishop and then
rook captures and b5 will be checkmate
and look at this uh
white king on b4 uh b4 usually an
excellent square for white pieces
especially you know if it's the opening
but uh not so much maybe maybe the king
but yeah
uh luckily he did get his uh harry d h
pawn all the way to g7 but
it didn't work out in this game and
daniel uh daniel won the match he won
the match by winning all of the game
simon got a draw in one of the games so
it was not um
not a completely one-sided match but uh
it was it was
not an easy one one for simon uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
and that you've
learned something from this game there's
not much to learn
except you know do play the sicilian
with both white and black pieces and
you know good things will happen uh so
yeah once again hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank uh michelle
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual uh you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful mr dodgy event 2.0
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess
world uh so do uh keep on suggesting
games from this tournament as there are
a lot of them
that they play like 10 games uh oh well
for
i think first uh uh first the five and a
half points i think it's 10 games or
maybe even 12 games i'm not really sure
but it's a lot of blitz games so if you
guys have one in particular that you
like
use hashtag suggestion in the comments
so i can find your game
uh and also as you can see in the top
left of the
of the corner uh age of kaisa chapter
two is coming soon so i know you guys
probably already forgot about age of
kaiser because we've released chapter
one last year
uh but now chapter two is coming and
then chapter three should be arriving
fairly quickly so i'm gonna make a
separate video on that but just to let
you guys know
that uh that's still a thing uh so yeah
once again hope you guys enjoyed it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon you know how it goes
see you soon